up this hour they say the first casualty
of war is truth and that appears to be
the case in russia's invasion of ukraine
the kremlin has banned anyone from
disputing their favorable narrative of
the war under penalty of imprisonment
but across the world volunteers are
reaching out to russian citizens in
unusual ways trying to break through
that censorship from london roxanna
seberry has the story
yawn as this cyber security expert calls
himself says the website he helped set
up to reach random people in russia has
placed him in the kremlin's crosshairs
dangerous he says because people around
the world have clicked on it more than
50 million times sending pre-drafted
messages about the war in ukraine like
putin is attacking cities and helpless
people he's lying and women children and
the elderly are
dying we want to
start a peaceful dialogue why is it
needed they cannot
obtain the truth
about
the war in ukraine
in russia the government has essentially
criminalized the spread of information
opposing its own narrative on the war
most independent media like tv rain have
shut down
and twitter and facebook are blocked
during the cold war the u.s used to
crack the kremlin's wall of censorship
radio free europe combats the soviet
life with radio programs and
anti-communist leaflets carried in
balloons
today's grassroots efforts are more
advanced
this website call russia randomly
generates 40 million numbers inside
russia so volunteers like tomas can make
calls from his office in lithuania
he asks what do you think about the war
in ukraine
the man answers i don't see anything
good in it
paula sinuta who helped launch the site
tells this woman russian bombs are
killing ukrainian civilians
she replies it's bad when people die but
then echoes the kremlin saying from what
i see it's the neo-nazis in ukraine who
sparked the war most of people don't
want to learn the truth
but people still are humans you know no
one is okay with massive
amounts of people dying so you're trying
to appeal to their humanity
absolutely these campaigners say they'll
keep reaching out to russians to share
the realities of the war
in the hope that eventually they'll help
end it for cbs saturday morning roxanna
saberi london